foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
I'm Piers Morgan I'm censored tonight
the high court rules that Prince Harry
cannot hire the British police force for
his own private security just days after
he ripped up a frenzy about his Security
in New York
Harry's big PR gamble over all this
spectacularly backfired a Christian
School teacher is struck off reportedly
for misgendering of trans people in the
first case of its kind in the UK he
joins me live
Foster Village People are threatening to
sue Donald Trump for using the legendary
Anthem YMCA yes young man
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored
well good evening London welcome to
Piers Morgan and sensored I was going to
start tonight's show with a little
monologue about Prince Harry whining
again being called again moaning about
security again the usual stuff it's not
uninteresting he lost a big case today
and his ongoing battle with the British
government over his right to have
proper Royal protection whenever he's in
the United Kingdom and he wants us the
British taxpayer to pay for him or if
that's not the case he wants the right
to pay for it himself well that right
today has been rejected and we're going
to come to that debate in a moment but
can't get out of my head something I
watched earlier I just can't I'm trying
to but it's lurking in my membranes
like a large lizard
because I can't quite believe what I
heard this is Ed Davis it is a knight of
the realm in the United Kingdom he's had
the tap on the shoulder from whoever it
was the queen or William or Charles or
somebody
for his services to this country because
it's supposedly an intelligent man and
yet on this morning with Nick Ferrari on
LBC Radio he was asked that whole
question
what's a woman what do they look like
and this is what he said
think about it and debate it with a bit
more maturity and a bit more compassion
well that's what secure Starman once
said to me and he never did answer the
question can a woman have a penis
well I've just answered that question
they can
um listen I've made it really clear that
if people
um uh the vast majority people will have
the same gender as their biological sex
but a small number one so a woman can
have a penis well quite clearly
what
sorry
what do you mean quite clearly
what are you talking about
quite clearly women can have penises
what are you talking about you are the
leader of a major national political
party in this country
you've already seen the first Minister
Scotland lose her job for being unable
to defend women's rights for thinking
it's fine for a male rapist to be put in
a women's prison she had to go we've
seen secure starmer wriggling around let
me just watch a bit of kirst armor
trying to explain what a woman is
for 99. I don't know nine percent of
women everything is a matter of biology
for
99.9 something percent of women
um it's all biological and it's very
straightforward and let me be clear for
the for the vast majority of women this
is all about biology and of course they
don't have a penis we all know that I
don't think we can conduct this
debate with
you know sorry no no no it's just no no
I just
a woman can't have a penis I don't think
that
um discussing this issue in this way
helps
that's Shakira another Knight of the
realm knighted because he's a smart
lawyer intelligent man also failing to
explain
simply what a woman is which of course
is just an adult human female it's not a
trick question this ever used to be a
controversial thing
and yet he can't answer
and now sir Ed Davey has taken it to a
new level altogether
let's just replay what Ed Davis said
again just to really try and comprehend
exactly what he's saying
I think we need to manage this and think
about it and debate it with a bit more
maturity and a bit more compassion well
that's what sakir Starman once said to
me and he never did answer the question
can a woman have a penis
well I've just answered that question
they can
um well listen I've made it really clear
that if people
um uh the vast majority of people will
have the same gender as their biological
sex but a small number one so a woman
can have a penis well quite clearly
it's unbelievable isn't it isn't it
or have I got mad
unbelievable in 2023
this is now something that political
leaders are saying that women can have
penises
they can't
it's a biological fact it's not
transphobic it's not about trans rights
I absolutely believe that trans people
should have rights to fairness and
equality like everybody else in life
regardless of any anything else
but you cannot deny biological
scientific fact and when two of the
three major political parties in this
country are run by men who are denying
biological fact with these public
statements
what does that say to women in this
country
who's defending their rights
who is explaining what a woman is who's
standing up for women
who is just telling the country what a
woman is it's unbelievable anyway rant
over
but I have had that clip in my head all
day and I can't get out of my head
thank God Rishi soon at the Prime
Minister when I asked him that question
at number 10 down the street just simply
reply it's an adult human female that's
all that needs to be said like a man is
an adult human male and trans people are
trans people
and everyone should get respected but
you can't deny biological fact
right
spell that off my chest
um let's turn to Prince Harry the last
time I said is identifying as a very
irritating adult human male I'm joined
now by the author and historian Dr Tessa
Dunlop from achieving two maintenance at
the vegetable of the police Dal Babu and
talk to you these Royal editor Syracuse
and right Sarah
just bring us up to speak because
Harry's involved in about a thousand
legal actions at the moment against the
world
what is the thing that happened today
and why is it significant
today a judge decided that you're
identifying as a woman right I am indeed
uh Harry couldn't uh have a judicial
review on his request to pay for his own
security when he comes to the UK so when
he was still a member of the royal
family working member of the royal
family he was entitled to 24 7 police
protection paid for by the taxpayer when
he stepped down in 2020 he lost that
automatic right he's got another legal
challenge which is about the decision to
remove that automatic right this in
particular was about him wanting to pay
for it he made the offer that he would
fund it the Metropolitan Police said
we're not guns for hire the home office
said it would be inappropriate and today
the judge has decided that it isn't
right it would set a wrong precedent
because effectively you could have all
kinds of wealthy people coming into the
UK saying well we want to hire
Metropolitan
win the review about the basic principle
of whether he should be allowed moral
protection when he's here yes and that
review looks set the way in which the
decision was made and the fact that he
wasn't part of that decision so it's not
over yet and actually he could still
appeal against this part of it but for
now he can't take it further he does
still have we don't have a date set for
the other wider case about him losing
his security it's about automatic
security as well because actually it
will be judged on a case-by-case basis
so when he was back for the coronation
he was part of the security bubble he
was protected because he was attending a
Royal Engagement this is about when he
comes back to his family right no you've
been a you know senior police officer in
this country as a British taxpayer
regardless of my personal feelings about
Harry and everything else just as a
British taxpayer why should I be paying
just on principle for someone who's quit
the royal family quit Royal Duty gone
off to America now makes hundreds of
millions of dollars
normally by trashing his family whatever
you can take a view either way on
whether you agree with that it's not
really relevant but why should somebody
who's made that conscious decision to
exit both the country and the royal
family and Royal Duty why should they
get such a perk when they come back here
of being protected by our Royal
protection Squad well I think that's a
legitimate Challenge and I think that's
what a lot of people are asking what do
you think well I I don't think he should
be entitled to that because I think he
he's not a royal working Royal if you're
a working war or no matter where you are
in a pecking order then you have that
right to be protected he's essentially
it's a commercial Enterprise now with
Prince Harry he's a celebrity yeah so
he'll come along and he'll want to he'll
want that all the resources there we
don't actually know how much policing
the royal family costs so essentially
he's unaware of what what that cost
would be so in terms of the process now
he will if there is a legitimate Target
placed on him if there's any
intelligence place on him he will be
like everybody else have uh police
protection right specifically for that
but I think what he's asking for is
General protection 24 7 which he's been
used to all his life I think he's now
finding extremely difficult to realize
that working as a celebrity working on a
commercial basis then the world is
totally different
Tessa why why should we be paying for
him to have unfettered access to one of
the top protection squads in the country
I'm going to explain to you in a sec why
I think we need to flip
flip so initially the point or rather
pose another question is once the
principle was a prince and I think
what's interesting about Harry's case is
the naivety the presumption that
everything that was around him he wore
like a second skin if you have 24-hour
security from the day that you're born
you probably don't actually realize
where the line is what's being Royal and
what's just being a regular bloke
celebrity or not and I think it's been
hard for him to shed that print skin he
never will it's one of the reasons why
he's a global celebrity but peers the
good news is and it's somewhere to turn
your attention in the future if Harry
isn't deemed to be a success at risk to
need this protection and we've we the
public have shed that Royal skin for him
then I would counter why don't we start
examining the bloated security bill that
so many of the royal family guzzle and
incidentally we don't know how much that
cost is it's higher than the Sovereign
Grant they think because whenever people
put in an information
um FYI on it they don't get a receipt
you would take away oh hang on for
working Royals who are Day by day doing
their Duty for the country and in return
they get protection because there are
lots of people out there that may want
to harm them their targets right we know
that they've been attacked before right
you would take all that away no you're
putting words in my mouth some of the
Lesser Royals don't which are the
working walls would you take it away
well for instance I mean did you get hot
under the collar as you have just done
now on gender and Harry about Eugenie in
2009 having a security brief they don't
have security involving two policemen
who went with her on a gap year to
Cambodia in Thailand just just to be
clear to be clear that I was out I was
out with both her and her sister
recently for lunch they have no 2009 she
had two working policemen with her and
Cambodia I I'm just saying did you did
you know that I know but I'm saying
actually we have a vast security bill
for lesser Royals to people like Sophie
and Anne needs security if Harry and
Megan everybody don't have 24 7.
security when they're on royally they
have security and often their properties
have 24 7 security paid for by us but I
think what you'll find now this whole
debate will perhaps look at what is the
cost of protecting royal family
generally yeah and I don't I don't think
Harry has got a clue around what the
cost is I mean I remember when the queen
and Prince Philip attended Enfield it
was a huge operation not just the plot
team the the specific plot team but on
top of that you would have had every
single venue would have to be searched
by licensed surge officers you'd have to
ensure that's expensive yeah absolutely
so all of that expense becomes quite
significant and I was talking to
Princess Diana's former body guard Ken
Wolfe hugely respected individual yeah
and Ken was saying it is quite shocking
that during this incident in New York
which I ironically was days before this
ruling well I don't think it was
coincidence but you you end up with a
situation where they've jumped into
they're worried about security put them
in a taxi they're put into taxi no idea
who the driver is no and the driver's
gone on sold his story and one of you
they've then sat went back and sat in a
police station now if you had these are
people that were put on Obama's secret
service detail a part of this Protection
Team apparently well I mean it seems
incredibly amateurish the way it was
done I totally agree and if you had
somebody with the skill level that the
British the British police have they
would have looked at the journey where
the journey was going to go where the
individuals were going to go what was
going to happen all of those
eventualities would have gone you
wouldn't be jumping in in the back of a
minicab so I did find it and it's
interesting how it's played out as
necessarily because when it first broke
that story yeah I was at home I was like
oh wow this looks really serious what's
happened here this is memories of Diana
and everything else there's been no
footage there's been no pictures there's
been nothing this is New York City Upper
East Side at 10 o'clock at night on a
Friday or whatever it was right it would
be Rand with people with cameras nothing
there's no evidence that there was
anything like a two-hour high-speed
chase through Manhattan it's not even
possible the traffic wouldn't allow it
and then they'd stick them in a tab
which goes round welcome then comes back
and so this goes on all to protect them
from revealing where they were staying
well this is about a standoff between
Harry and the media isn't it because
Harry did not want the paparazzi to get
a photo of him and he's paying for that
security he's literally just been yeah
but he's just been at a massive that's
not his terms though for his wife to get
us completely spurious Awards of being
the world's most inspiring woman the
reason to baffle me but anyway east of
Their Own
self-aggrandizing media event where of
course it's in the middle of Manhattan
it's in Midtown Manhattan crawling in
Paparazzi of course it is of course
they're going to follow them wherever
they think they're going to be going why
stay at a private residence you want to
keep private why not go to the hotel
like they normally do I mean it's a
battle of wills isn't it he doesn't want
them to get what they want if it's not
on their terms he doesn't want them to
have that photograph and if you're
paying for the security and you've said
to your security detail your one job is
to make sure they don't get a photograph
yeah it's different but Tessa here's my
problem here's my problem with this they
just I don't know what it is I don't
know what is really motivated whether
it's just a blind hatred of all the
media so any tiny thing they want to
blow out of all proportions so that it
looks like they're being hunted or
whatever but everyone I've spoken to
about this incident in New York has said
it just was not anything like the near
catastrophe they were painting I can see
there is a contradiction between their
hunger for celebrity and their desire
for privacy but appears I'm asking of
you to try and find some sort of empathy
I know you weren't born a prince I know
you're a poorper done good but the
bottom line is that boy had everything
and it is far harder climbing down in
life than it is climbing up and he has
bucket loads of anxiety to do with his
childhood to do with the way in which
you know you know what his woman it's
difficult for them and they're gonna
have to keep them here's my room here is
my honest response to that right he has
brought all of this on himself he hasn't
picked because of what he goes on like
he's the only person to lose a parent
apart from anything else right
I lost my father died when I was one
right William lost his mother at the
same time Harry didn't he doesn't behave
like this this guy's quit the country
quit Royal Duty quit everything gone to
California lives in a wonderful mansion
and he sells his family down the river
for vast amounts of cash every chance he
gets I have no sympathy he's at all but
he's naive and he was to the manor born
and you asked Al Harry every day will be
working out how he pays for that
gigantic security brief to keep his
paranar in check how much does it cost
be honest to give someone like Eugenie
or Anne or Sophie protect yourself
they get him and they're on Royal Duty
yeah we haven't got the figures but but
I mean I think the difficulty it is an
enormous figure I think the difficulty
is with Harry I don't think he
understands how the world Works in terms
of how all that intelligence comes in
the briefings that will have to be done
and do you actually want somebody
walking down the High Street to protect
you or solving your Burgers solving
crime what he wants he wants to he wants
I think he just wants to have his raw
cake and eats it it basically boils down
to that he wants to be like he tried to
propose to the queen half in half out he
wants some good stuff the Celebrity
Status the money the the trappings the
Royal protection you just want to put
the shift in you know in clear thoughts
on a wet Wednesday you know going to an
old people's home and that's not the
deal that the public has with the royal
family it's just not that the deal is
they do all that stuff hundreds and
hundreds of times a year and in return
they get the trappings and they get the
security and everything else I mean his
argument would be well I was born a
prince I didn't choose the way I was
born I am still a prince look at Prime
Ministers former Prime Ministers still
get their protection they do why should
they choose it yeah uh regardless of how
long they serve they did he did so
that's such a good point Sarah she's the
winner nobody would ever question the
servers he gave his country at least of
all me so let's keep his protection when
he's here I wish that guy was still that
guy that's all I can say my
brother-in-law taught them as Sandhurst
William and Harris he was a great little
soldier but do you know what if he got
his protection he'd come over why do you
ask give you more stuff ask a hundred
soldiers what they think of Harry at the
moment well I mean Harry Harry he's been
doing today went out he he actually
broke the code he talked about going out
there shooting I mean he posted about it
yeah
guys have done that yeah but he's made
himself more vulnerable I agree he's
more of a he's more he's not he's not
particularly bright I think he knows
when you go out there you think all the
people that would perhaps want to do him
harm he wanted to add to that and says
look I've killed absolutely right it was
just I don't think I think there's too
much wacky backy in California
unfortunately but that's just an
allegation
unsubstantiated apart from regular
confessions in his book thank you to my
star panel much appreciated uncensored
next a Christian teacher is banned to
the profession for using the wrong
pronouns for transgender people it's the
first case of his kind in the UK and he
joins me live
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at 7
pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to Piers Morgan and sensor
Joshua Sutcliffe was a math teacher at
the travel School in Oxford that was
until one lesson in 2017 when he praised
a group of female students on their hard
work or one of the girls identifies as a
transgender boy and this week in the
first case of his kind in the UK Joshua
succulent was banned from every
classroom in England for not using the
pupils preferred pronouns Mr suck this
so he apologized immediately and is
being persecuted because of his
Christian beliefs and he joins me now
well thank you for coming on Facebook
when I send it thank you pierce just
tell me exactly what happened
um well it was the tra hearing
um in recent months then the principal
reason that they Banned Me from every
classroom in the UK as you mentioned was
for refusing to use the pronouns um that
a particular student wanted to so what
did you actually say you called the
group girls yeah I was two two girls at
the front of the class and one of them
identified as a boy and I agree with the
policy exchange report recently released
by the government where it says that you
know we're letting down a generation of
young people affirmingham in these
um you know dispositions
um you know in the UK you need a gender
recognition certificate and that is post
18 and so um it really is a serious
issue and it's effective schools Across
the Nation and so I mean we're seeing a
lot of kids now identifying as something
other than their biological sex what do
you think of that phenomenon well I
think it's really something our society
should be taking much more seriously
um you know it's a path these students
go down a path of taking very strong
drugs and surgery and it's something
that shouldn't be so quickly brought
into classrooms across the country and
it's happening uh everywhere as you've
seen in the news reports not just for me
but for other teachers you call these
two students girls one of them was a
transgender Boy by her own or his own
definition whichever you want to say it
right this is a time this is you know
five six years ago when this issue
wasn't anyone as prevalent as it is now
did you realize immediately this might
be a problem
uh I well I wasn't really um Savvy I
didn't know about the issue as we've
come to know you're at it and um you
know but at the time with my Christian
convictions I thought an appropriate
stance to
um you know uh just use the student's
name and what happened to you
um well I mean the school sort of took a
case against me and it's ended out all
the way at the what were you accused of
doing accused of using the wrong
pronouns literally literally yeah
accused of using the wrong pronouns and
that was actually the principal reason
that the Department of Education used
against me
um that I refused to use the pronouns so
really quite a shocking and sad day for
myself personally but even for England
at you know I mean the argument that was
put forward against you was that you
should treat all pupils of dignity and
respect and if they're identifying in a
different way then you should feel
mandated to do that well I think the
safeguarding of the pupil is Paramount
in this situation and if you affirm
these students in their gender identity
then that could lead them down a path
um that maybe the one day they will get
regret and you know maybe it's something
that we should think about
um you know leaving for adults to decide
rather than such young students I'm
going down this path see on on this I'm
kind of you know I'm kind of sympathetic
to to what you're saying about that
issue that the pronoun misgendering and
so on with so many kids now following
what I think in most cases is just a fad
why should people have to change their
language to accommodate what seems to be
just a fact the complication I think in
your case is that you have very strong
Christian beliefs or I would say beliefs
that pertain to your religion would you
accept that I accept that pierce yeah so
you have uh four Abominations on your
website for example yes um abortion
homosexuality porn and Islam yes you
call them Abominations yes is right well
I mean when I read that I was like hang
on is it right that any teacher
should be teaching kids if they call
those four things Abominations we
understand Pierce those things happened
outside of the classroom you know that's
my own personal I understand that yeah
understand that but in one case it was
cited that you had for example on the
issue of gay marriage you'd said to kids
in the class that it should be between a
man and woman yeah a student asked me
about my conviction and that was what I
said that they should marriage should be
between a man and a woman but um you
know the Bible very clearly describes
many things as sinful and as not good
things for us and the Bible also tells
you to Stone people for various offenses
and we don't do that anymore I mean the
point is well we all deserve I mean I'm
a Catholic but I wouldn't I wouldn't use
language like these are all Abominations
particularly when a lot of people in
this country are now gay obviously you
think that that's abominable yes um and
that's fine that's your it's your
prerogative to have that opinion but
there will be people who think well hang
on this these are pretty hardcore views
of someone who wants to teach young
children I understand that people might
disagree with me Pierce but I'm I'm
that's a pretty Orthodox Christian view
to think that these things are sinful
and not
um good I don't know any Christians who
say Islam is an abomination
well I know some but they're not it's
not Orthodox well that's not Orthodox
Christian teaching of course it's
standard Christian teaching you know to
not agree with Islam and you know to not
that it's an Abomination another
religion there's respect for Islam but I
respect Muslims very much peace you
don't you call their religion an
Abomination you must separate ideas from
people people listen on your website you
say Islam is an Abomination that's not
respecting a religion well it's the
opposite of respecting a religion no I
disagree very much with Islam yes that's
fine it's entirely your prerogative I'm
just saying that if you want to be a
teacher is it compatible with being a
teacher to have a personal website which
lists a series of Abominations including
the right to be gay the right to have an
abortion legal pornography Islam another
massive religion one and a half billion
people it just seems to me if I was a if
I was a parent at that school and I read
that on your website I would be
concerned well I think it's up to
parents to look these things up if they
want to but all parents that I've um had
interactions with would say that I'm a
very respectable man and I'm always I
did the job at hand but I think in our
free Society I think that I'd be able to
share those things outside the classroom
you now go into the street and you you
talk just watch a little clip of what
you do
that there's one way
into heaven
his name is Jesus Christ
this is an urgent plea with your spirit
man I'm not just talking to your minds
I'm talking to your spirit to your heart
that you might be awoken from the death
of this generation
that you might be shaken out of the
depths of darkness and into the Glorious
light of the kingdom of God
I mean again I'm not sure I feel that
comfortable about having a teacher of my
young kid who's out there doing that
every weekend
um you know it's pretty Orthodox
Christian beliefs that I'm it's fine but
your teacher out there basically ranting
away in the street it doesn't it
wouldn't lend itself to most parents to
think that that is entirely compatible
with teaching kids well you'd have to
see me in the classroom Pierce I'm a
good practitioner when were you last in
a classroom if well three or four years
ago now you want to teach again I'd love
to teach it again I enjoy teaching my
dad's a teacher and I've what does your
dad make of all this he said he supports
me yeah
yeah disagree with all your views
um well he's a Christian himself Pierce
he was an artist he was an re teacher
for for um 30 years but does he agree
that all these things are Abominations
well appears this is Biblical teaching
it's not it shouldn't be a surprise to
you or anyone else well like I said the
Bible also teaches people to Stone
people to death but we don't do that
well that's the civilization that's the
penalty for sin Pierce but Jesus so for
adultery you would have died well just
to clarify then for adultery you think
is right to Stone people to death I
think that as they do in Saudi Arabia
for example yeah all sin deserves the
death penalty and Jesus so adulterers
are saying let me finish please it's an
important point is adultery a sin
Jesus died on the cross for Sinners he
took the place Joshua is adultery a sin
yes so you want to execute everyone is
doing an adultery all sin all 613 true
demons all sin is is punishable by death
right Joshua that's nuts mate and that's
what the Bible and that's the problem
you see peace you start off you have me
at the start you had me about the
pronoun issue because I think it's
incredibly complicated and I don't see I
also have a big concern about number of
kids who are basically putting their
hands up saying I'm a woman I'm a girl
I'm a boy with a knot and so on
um but this stuff is nuts mate if you're
going to say that everyone who's a
sinner by the rule of the Bible has to
be killed there's no one left deserves
only you left and I don't feel
comfortable about the world and with
only just me Joshua suck live a life
don't be silly I am the worst of Sinners
peers but why are you still alive
because Christ has died for Sinners he
took the place they were by your
yardstick you should be executed yes I
should be goodbye God he's the judge of
all but you're gonna I'm gonna go and
submit yourself for execution no but
Jesus is it's called penal substitution
huh it's called it's a it's a
theological
when you talk that way it disqualifies
you in my eyes from being a teacher not
the pronoun stuff I'm that I'm with you
on this stuff it's nuts we should be in
a free Society totally and you're by the
way allowed up as many nutty views as
you like I just don't think Nazi in your
opinion I think your opinion in 99 of
the entire planet your views are nothing
your world maybe but no people don't
think that everyone who commits adultery
should be executed tomorrow no uh this
is what the Bible teaches greed
this is what the Bible teaches to be put
to death and this and this isn't really
being taught in our generation no
there's a reason it's not taught in our
generation but Christ is completely
sacrificed for sin yes I know Jesus
Christ did sacrifice himself but you
don't think Jesus Christ will be sitting
here today at my desk saying every
single person who commits an act of
greed or gluttony or adultery should be
summarily executed if you do think
Judgment of God you do think that you
have a very warped idea well actually
the Bible is supposed to mean no I think
what's happened is you've got your own
view of what the Bible says but you
haven't really ever been told what the
Bible says I've read the Bible I was
actually given spiritual guidance by
Catholic nuns when I was 11 years old uh
for a couple of years I'm very very very
sad with the Bible but honestly when I
hear people say that for all these sins
you've got to be put to death it's nuts
so for that you shouldn't be teaching
well Christ has taken our place Pierce
and I think I should be well
unfortunately uh someone from YMCA is
about to take your place uh on the show
I'm afraid and that's it but good to see
you thank you Joshua sugden since the
next Village People are taking you on
Donald Trump over his unauthorized use
of their iconic anthems a village person
will debate that with me live if he
hasn't sinned too much in the break
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
thank you
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel no
we're gonna use uh every little helps
for God's sake is nothing original
anymore it's finger licking Goods I'm
loving it look let's be honest we don't
have any fancy speech writers here but
we do and I promise you discuss the
issues that matter to you yes I'm back
talk TV not with Morgan just before him
Monday to Thursday at 7pm join me just
do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
and still sinning you probably recognize
this disco anthem
[Music]
well why I'm saying by the British
people has been the soundtrack of
wedding's bar mitzvahs and pretty much
every drunken night I had as a teenager
or recently it's become the unlikely
soundtrack of Donald Trump's rallies in
America
[Music]
this will do the Trump
it's actually quite a Nifty mover but
the group has now threatened to sue
Trump over the use of their music and
are looking like band that played at his
Mar-A-Lago estate without their
permission they argue that fans now
believe the real Village People are
endorsing Donald Trump and they
threatened well basically go to Legal
war with him
so there's a long list of artists have
argue they don't want to be associated
with Trump in the past and I'm joined
now from Atlanta by the British peoples
linked to Willis and by Maga rapper
Forgiato blow who's in Florida well
welcome to both of you Victor Lewis uh
thank you very much indeed for joining
me Willis thank you sir I feel like a
part of my a part of my life has just
appeared on screen so thank you for all
the entertainment over the years
thank you Mr Morgan how are you doing
I'm great thank you now your wife Karen
I believe is leading the legal battle
with Donald Trump over this on behalf of
the ban what is your problem with Donald
Trump using your music and and looking
like bands and so on
well first of all let me again thank you
for having me on the show
um
as far as Donald Trump is concerned let
me uh say that
the president Donald Trump
um
I like the fact that he likes my music
as far as him using playing the music
um I asked him a long time ago not to
play the music but but at the same time
legally he has a right to play it I mean
anybody can play that wants to the
particular problem came along When
Donald Trump decided to have some people
dress up like Village People right and
have them at Mar-A-Lago performing to uh
the song that I wrote and it was singing
and it made it become a situation to
where I got a lot of calls and a lot of
emails from people and fans Etc that
were like really upset by the fact that
they thought that we were endorsing
Trump and this is where the confusion
became to where my wife who is the
manager of Village People at the same
time she's a Juris Doctrine lawyer uh I
myself am the original lead singer and
writer I wrote all the songs YMCA Macho
Man Etc right maybe and um we were
bombarded by a lot of fans that were
were upset by the fact that they thought
that the people that were performing at
Mar-A-Lago were actually the Village
People I got it you know whereas Village
People we're not we're uh we we stay out
of politics we're not a political group
we do not we wouldn't endorse Trump and
we wouldn't endorse a Democrat okay you
wouldn't endorse anybody out of that I
got evicted let me go to Forgiato so
this is not really an anti-republican
thing for the other this is basically a
we want to stay out of politics
altogether thing shouldn't that be
respected if if those people one of the
great bands in the world you've
entertained the world if they just want
to say look we don't want to get
political at all shouldn't they have
that right
no I don't think in the world right now
I mean
we have a platform and we're teaching
you know the new generation which Trump
is also putting on their song
um I understand they don't want to be
political bouncy it's a problem I mean
there's five to eight-year-old girls
around the world dressed up by their
favorite princess singing Frozen are we
going to stop them from doing that every
single day I don't see what the problem
is I just feel like it's an attack on
Trump anything Trump does people say you
know Trump is above the law he's not
he's under the law they go out Trump for
everything
um so I just think it's an issue I don't
think that's a problem I think he's all
right well let me ask you a question get
bigger all right we'll judge it what's
been your biggest hit
uh my biggest song is actually a mega
song it's called vanilla Sprite with
Rick Ross and Vanilla Ice
um but four more years probably my
biggest song but if Joe Biden or BLM or
any type of organization wanted to play
my music I really want to care that was
going to be my question so you you
wouldn't mind if Joe Biden did that at
his rallies your song no because Trump's
not being negative playing it he's got
to dance he's making everybody in
America especially this America we're
living in right now happy again you know
making America
doing the negative he's he's being happy
he's not I could see if he was being
disrespectful to them they know their
Legends
let me bring Victory
come back to you let me interject here
thank you sir number one uh young man
you have a misconception of what I just
said I said we do not mind Donald Trump
playing the music because we don't care
who plays the music he has the right to
play the music as much as he wants that
has nothing to do with the particular
situation uh we would not we would not
be saying anything as a matter of fact
YMCA with him playing the music went all
the way back up to number two on the
billboard something that I wrote over 40
years ago so it is not a problem with
him playing the music matter of fact it
helped us as a group The Situation
became to where we had to put the cease
and desist out when he had people dress
up in our costumes and perform at
Mar-A-Lago which gave a lot of the fans
the impression that it was us as Village
People endorsing him as a political uh
idea okay let me bring in Forgiato to
respond to that I don't think nobody
thought the endorsement was going to
make a difference in what's going to
happen in this election I feel like
karaoke is not illegal people dress up
on Halloween we're going to stop we're
going to cancel Halloween people I mean
they're they their group they're dressed
up he's sitting as a police officer you
got constructed was he the first police
officer ever to be a police officer was
there in the first construction
I have a I have a confession to make I
actually went out let me finish I
actually went as Donald Trump
I do sorry I'm I'm running this
interview I actually went dressed as
Donald Trump to a Beverly Hills
Halloween party
so I didn't get his permission so I'm
kind of sympathetic to that but did you
get sued did you get us did you get a
cease and desist about it not yet Trump
trump gets a lot of hate from people who
don't know physically Metro Trump's a
nice guy great guy I've never seen
another negative in person about him I
just feel like it's they have a great
song they have a great music okay
let me another happy note Victor how
much money have you made from yes sir
how much money have you made from YMCA
well I've sold over 100 million records
over the years wow um so I can't so I I
mean you know I've sold quite a few
records
Etc again it was it was the fact that no
we get it we get it yeah but I think
these are the ones that approached that
started bombarding me with the fact of
of seeing uh somebody dressed as Village
People
they didn't pick you know if it's a
here's a thing they were doing it as a
tribute to you I mean there's actually a
different way of looking at it as
Forgiato says which is it's kind of
flattering isn't it I mean there must be
Village People tribute acts all over the
world you can't go around so well you
know if they if they had announced it
that that you know there are several
tribute groups that that perform I mean
you know if it was announced that here's
a tribute group to the Village People
performing my two-man whatever it would
be nothing to say I got it I mean
I think we're going to clarify to we'll
clarify to president Trump if you
introduces them as a tribute Act is fine
but if he tries and passes them off as
the real thing that can only be one one
Village People and only one Victor
Victor Willis and what an amazing star
you've been and the happiness you
brought to people in my generation and
many more but particularly mine because
my teenage years lit up with your music
they said it's a pleasure to have you on
the program and you Forgiato thank you
thank you so much thank you both very
much I appreciate it Trump 2024 let's go
says a woman can quite clearly have a
penis
quite clearly
that is Bonkers or debate that one
appears back next
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talk Eco zealots bring
chaos to the capital with more slow
marches before police put an R8 driver
in handcuffs Boris Johnson hits the
headlines as he's referred to police
over new lockdown breaking claims and
hold on to your hat it's been revealed
the average cost of attending a wedding
has soared to a thousand quid that's all
coming off at nine
[Music]
centers right
have you seen the other of you every day
why don't we even start with you guys
actually hang you uh and me and you
we're all doomed we're all doomed what
did you make of that interview I mean I
grew up in a Catholic household yeah I
did and I don't know anyone who acts
that fundamental about anything and you
know when I read the headline this
morning and we heard about you know and
you feel instinctively quite sympathetic
I think mostly you wouldn't obviously
because you're yeah okay well I read it
I knew immediately there's got to be so
much more to this there's no way he's
just you know slightly mispering there
is a lot more too yeah the more I'd
spoke to him and got out of him the more
extreme his views became right
um I mean the reality is on the pronouns
thing he's right yeah well you know it's
just it just that is not the right way
to be uh teaching and addressing people
in school there's no question do you
mean using the wrong pronouns isn't it
yeah but when you've got 10 of kids now
in some schools identifying as something
other than their brothers at that point
it is ridiculous to expect teachers to
even try and keep up with this madness
right it's insane it's absolutely it's
like 10 of them are doing it I'm gonna
do it it's honestly yeah that doesn't
matter you don't believe for a moment
the 10 of students in this country have
dysphoria do you yeah do you think that
transphobia is where homophobia was
about 10 years ago
I do and I think that people it's
unnecessary
issue I understand if a child might be
going off to seek some sort of therapy
and you need to let the parents know I
understand encouraging the discussion
questions
do you know why trans people are having
to put up with extra mockery and I feel
very strongly about this proper trans
people who are not just doing it for a
Fab but genuinely believe they're
trapped in the wrong body many of them
have surgery and so on I've known people
who've been through this it's an
incredible ordeal they go through when
they hear a leader of a political party
like sir Ed Davey of the liberal
Democrats saying this this is what
causes the problems we need to manage
this and think about it and debate it
with a bit more maturity and a bit more
compassion well that's what secure stoma
once said to me and he never did answer
the question can a woman have a penis
well I've just answered that question
they can
um listen I've made it really clear that
if people
um uh the vast majority people will have
the same gender as their biological sex
but a small number one so a woman can
have a penis well quite clearly
I think he gave a perfectly good answer
there quite clearly women I think you
can you ask a reductive question and you
get a reductive answer I mean clearly
women it's a biological question which
Demands a biological answer and he's
completely wrong if he is the leader of
the country it's absurd you don't
believe women have penises I do believe
that some trans women can have penis not
trans women women no come on don't be so
reductive with that question it's not
productive because if I answer that this
is why this is why women's sport is
being destroyed because people will not
distinguish between trans women and
women okay right well look cannot damage
biology you cannot deny biology you just
can't do it and political leaders say
clearly women have penises you know what
happens trans people real trans people
they get mocked and they get vilified
for it that's what increases trans
person perhaps people genuinely do feel
they're trapped in the wrong body
perhaps Ed Davey is referring to real
trans people who feel they are trapped
in the wrong body
why as a woman are you not keen to
protect women's rights to be women I
don't think it affects my rights
whatsoever what does it does what does
affect my rights being put in female
you've got male sprinters and swimmers
and cyclists destroying biological
females at sport what more evidence do
you need yes none of that is a threat to
me do you know what is a threat to me
the fact that I I can't walk home at
night safely the fact that I know the
difference reported go to conviction for
an issue this it's not a difference
because you're arguing that men are
dangerous and they shouldn't be in
women's spaces that's what I agree with
I've got no problem with coming with you
on that journey to make places safer for
women you don't make places safe for a
Woman by allowing male rapists into
women's prisons because they go Tada I'm
a woman it's [__] anyway let's agree
about one thing before we finish which
is that there is one great woman in this
country that after the Queen's uh very
sad death there's one left in my
estimation other than my mother
obviously and his Dame Joan Collins the
magical Dame Joan who today turned 90
years old probably won't thank me for
reminding her uh but she looks about 50.
looks younger than me happy birthday
Dame Joan you are a proper woman and we
salute you on this show thank you pack
Joan Collins that woman
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
thank you
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored